today on the Matt Walsh show as
prominent Democrats openly advocate for
eugenics and Canada drastically expands
its euthanasia program we'll take a look
at the origins and intentions of the
left's war on human life also some
exciting updates on our rally tomorrow
Nashville plus speaking of exciting
Alexandria Casa Cortez continues to be
shouted down by Angry constituents at
her Town Hall events and I think it's
just great also test scores have fallen
dramatically in the public school system
they're still blaming it on the pandemic
but I think there's a lot more to the
story in our daily cancellation a
Congressional candidate offers a bizarre
defense of what she calls our quote
right to sex we'll talk about all that
and much more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
Roe versus Wade has been overturned and
this battle is now finally leaving DC
and going to the Grassroots no group in
America is better positioned than 40
Days for life for this fight with about
a million volunteers and 1 000 cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities they have a
larger presence in blue states with
California being their largest state
some former abortion facility directors
say these vigils can cause the abortion
no show rate to go as high as 75 percent
which is detrimental to their abortion
business these law-abiding vigils have
closed many abortion businesses in
America and nearly half of those closed
abortion facilities were in Liberal
cities where abortions remain and will
remain legal including closures in San
Francisco Chicago and Seattle four days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and Minds in the Grassroots to end
abortion you can check out their
locations podcasts and free magazine at
40daysforlife.com it's important that
you support four days for life in their
work because as we know even with the
end of Roe v Wade this fight is far from
over so for more information
four days for Life go to
40daysforlife.com
so yesterday we briefly discussed
comments made by Stacy Abrams where she
proposed a novel solution to our
economic woes as Abrams explained all we
need to do is just kill more children in
case you missed that clip well here it
is again
you're running for governor of Georgia
uh I would assume maybe incorrectly but
while abortion is an issue it nowhere
reaches the level of interest of Voters
in terms of the cost of gas
food bread milk things like that what
can a governor what could you do as
governor to alleviate the concerns of
Georgia voters about those livability
daily hourly issues that they're
confronted with but let's be clear
having children is why you're worried
about your price for gas it's why you're
concerned about how much food costs for
women this is not a reductive issue you
can't divorce being forced to carry an
unwanted pregnancy from the economic
realities of having a child and so these
are it's important for us to have both
and conversations we don't have the
luxury of reducing it or separating them
out but we also have to talk about what
a governor can do a governor can address
housing prices a governor can address
the cost of Education a governor can put
money into the pockets of everyday
hard-working Georgians instead of giving
tax cuts to the wealthy that's what I
talk about on the trail and that's
what's resonating but let's not pretend
that women half the population
especially those of childbearing age
they understand that having a child is
absolutely an economic issue
now I called this a novel solution but
of course that isn't really true there's
nothing novel about it the Democrat
Party has always promoted abortion as a
path to Financial Security and the logic
is simple it's morally depraved but
simple kids cost money
get rid of the kids
get rid of the expense
financial prosperity awaits allegedly
even though it doesn't actually work out
that way this is the eugenic engine that
has driven the pro-abortion movement
since its Inception it's just that only
recently have the pro board started to
once again be more open in their
eugenicism advocacy and I say once again
because years ago
uh before the movement went through a
series of rebrands and they started
talking more about so-called
reproductive health and all the rest of
it before that
um the pro abortion movement used to be
much more direct and explicit about
about all of this and about the fact
that it was advocating for eugenics back
in 1969 the vice president of Planned
Parenthood at the time named Frederick
Jeff
at the request of an organization called
the population Council produced a memo
with a number of recommendations for how
the government could control population
growth this is the jaff memo as it's now
called and it outlines a series of
strategies all falling under four broad
categories and those categories are
social constraints economic deterrence
social controls and preventing unwanted
pregnancy
so just to highlight a few here and we
put the memo up on screen so you can see
it yourself just a few
Jeff suggested restructuring the family
encouraging people to post postpone or
avoid marriage
he coupled this with compulsory
government education and an
encouragement of increased homosexuality
he also recommended that women should
work outside the home under the
deterrent category he listed a number of
strategies including the brilliant idea
that the government could
reduce population by fostering quote
chronic depression
it's actually it's actually on the memo
elsewhere in the memo he recommends the
wide distribution of contraception along
with sterilization and of course
tax-funded abortion now
some of his ideas like compulsory
abortion for out of wedlock pregnancies
that's one of the things that he
advocated that hasn't yet come to pass
but a great many of them have
in fact all the rest of the ones that I
just listed have
so the eugenesis they told us exactly
what they were going to do and why they
were going to do it
and then they did it and are still doing
it now
it took them several decades but Planned
Parenthood they even found a way to
implement their Mass sterilization plan
under the guise of gender affirmation
they now provide sterilization drugs to
children
so that is yet another box on the jaff
memo which has been checked off
this was the dystopian future that
Planned Parenthood predicted and
advocated for and and fought to
establish
and now we're living in it
actually we're living in something far
beyond it we might say because somewhat
surprisingly Frederick jaff never
thought of or at least didn't include in
his memo
the idea of simply just killing off
large numbers of adults and calling it a
medical treatment
put them down like dogs
euthanasia did not factor into his
calculations not on the memo anyway
perhaps he didn't have an imagination
Twisted enough to conjure up
possibilities like that at the time and
yet at some point
um in the in the Years following the
eugenicists did arrive at this
conclusion and now the death Merchants
are rapidly expanding their war on human
life last week I told you about a report
from a journalist named Rupa subramanya
who reveals the extent of the euthanasia
regime in Canada or the medical
assistance in dying as they call it
there
she Chronicles the plight of one
distraught mother you may recall who's
fighting to prevent her 23 year old son
from killing himself through euthanasia
her son like so many of the other doctor
assisted suicide quote patients in
Canada is not terminally ill terminally
he's just he's just depressed
and he know no longer wants to live
rather than provide him with mental and
emotional counseling
his doctors are simply going to kill him
that's their way around it
unless his mother can stop it though she
has no real legal means of doing so
in fact the euthanasia laws are
expanding so much in Canada and are
becoming so permissive
that by early next year they're expected
to start killing miners without parental
consent
although even if they did it with
parental consent that would be no less
horrifying
so Rupert provides more details on just
how pervasive this has become in the
country reading now she says in 2017 the
First full year in which made which is
medical assistance and dying which is
administered by provincial governments
was an operation
2838 people opted for assisted suicide
according to a government report by 2021
that figure had jumped to 10 064
accounting for more than three percent
of all deaths in Canada that year
there have been a total of 31
664 made deaths and the large majority
of those were people uh between the ages
of 65 to 80 when they died in 2017 only
34 made deaths were in the 18 to 45 year
old category in 2018 and that figure
Rose to at least 49.
in 2019 it was 103 in 2020 it was 118
and in 2021 it was 139. today thousands
of people who could live for many years
are applying successfully to kill
themselves indeed in some Canadian
provinces nearly five percent of deaths
are made deaths five percent
in 2021 the province of Quebec reported
that 4.7 percent of deaths in the
province were due to maid in uh British
Columbia the number was 4.8 percent
Progressive Vancouver Island is
officially or rather unofficially known
as the assisted death capital of the
world according to doctors
now the other thing to understand is
that those who apply for doctor-assisted
suicide can have their applications
accepted quickly the process is
streamlined
now that what that means is that you'll
have better luck in Canada getting
accepted for euthanasia than you would
for say getting a a building permit to
put an addition on your house
there's usually tons of red tape and it
takes forever to get approval from
anything through the bureaucracy and
that's the case in Canada and the United
States of course
but if you want to kill yourself well
they'll they'll get you through that
process quickly
the AP reported this a few months ago
quote Alan Nichols had a history of
depression and other medical issues but
none were life-threatening when the 61
year old Canadian was hospitalized in
June 2019 over fears he might be
suicidal he asked his brother to bust
him out as soon as possible
within a month Nichols submitted a
request to be euthanized and and he was
killed within a month
submit the request and was killed within
a month despite concerns raised by his
family and a nurse practitioner his
application for euthanasia listed only
one health condition as the reason for
his request to die hearing loss
Nichols family reported the case to
police and health authorities arguing
that he lacked the capacity to
understand the process and was not
suffering unbearably among the
requirements for euthanasia they say he
was not taking needed medication wasn't
using the implant that helped him hear
that hospital staff staffers improperly
helped him request euthanasia
now think about that for a second he was
sent to the doctor
he was sent to the hospital because he
was suicidal
and his family thought the hospital
would help save him from suicide and
instead according to the family
the staff at the hospital
helped him kill himself
they killed this man because he had
hearing loss
they'll also kill you in Canada if
you're homeless city news has a report
about a 54 year old name man named Amir
farsood in Ontario he applied for
medical assistance in dying and has
already received one of the two doctor's
letters of approval that he needs all
because he is potentially about to be
homeless
here's their report
how would you describe the quality of
your life
[Music]
um
awful non-existent terrible I do nothing
other than sort of managed symptoms
manage pain
there we go Amir farsood lives with
never-ending Agony from a back injury
how bad does it get
um
at worst that gets bad enough that I'm
crying like a five-year-old and not
sleeping for two days in a row
but that's not why he has applied for
medically assisted dying otherwise known
as maid nor is it the depression he
lives with farsood has applied because
he is in danger of losing his housing he
lives in this Saint Catherine's rooming
house sharing this space with two other
people but it is up for sale farsood
lives on social assistance and says he
can't find anywhere else he can afford
I don't want to die but I don't want to
be homeless more than I don't want to
die medically assisted dying in Canada
was expanded this past march to include
people with disabilities or those
suffering in pain even if they are not
close to death
now the thing to remember about this is
that uh it is not as though all of these
people would have killed themselves
anyway
and all Canada is doing is providing
them a
painless way of killing themselves
now if that were the case it would still
be horrifying it would still be a
horrifying reality
but it's not the case
you know there's it more people are
killing us people who would not have
otherwise people who would have who
would have uh who would have fought on
and continued living and found a way to
keep keep living and to deal with their
their problems someone like this for
example
I mean homelessness is a very real
problem and if you're going through that
or being threatened with something like
that or or you're worried about the
possibility of that it's a it is to call
it distressing of course would be an
understatement
but you can live through it you can
fight through it there's there's still
hope there's light at the end of the
tunnel
and a great many of these people they
would if they didn't have this system in
place to just Usher them off the planet
Usher them out of their own lives if
that system wasn't in place many of
these people would continue living
so I think Stacy Abrams when she sees
that she'd be proud
because rather than make the country our
country more livable for children Abrams
Abrams suggests that we simply kill them
and in Canada rather than address the
homelessness problem
they'll just start Exterminating them
rather than address the problem of
depression and despair and mental
illness
Just Kill Them All
they're not going to concern themselves
with coming up with policies or
strategies that may help human beings be
happy and flourish
No in fact it's the opposite because
human flourishing
is a negative in their minds
according to the powers that be
according to the leftists
human flourishing is a negative it's the
opposite of what they desire
human flourishing as the jaff memo
showed in 1969 is the problem that they
seek to solve
and they have spent decades solving it
now let's get to our five headlines
I love finding easy ways to support a
healthy routine which is why I'm so
excited about tart cherry gummies from
the makers of superbeets heart chews
tart cherry gummies are an easy way to
support your metabolic health and reduce
inflammation from exercise these gummies
are made with a clinically studied tart
cherry extract that is up to 40 times
more concentrated than many other tart
cherry extracts just two tart cherry
gummies are the antioxidant equivalent
of 16 ounces of tart cherry juice or 100
cherries so put all that tart cherry
juice away you don't need it all you
need are the gummies formulated by a
team of scientists led by Nobel
prize-winning doctors tarte Cherry has
been clinically studied to support
metabolic health I had tart cherry
gummies for the first time the other day
after finishing up a workout and I could
really feel the difference plus they're
delicious tart cherry gummies come with
a 100 satisfaction guarantee try them
risk-free for 90 days and see how you
feel if you don't love them send them
back no questions asked but I think you
will right now you can get up to 35 off
tart cherry gummies plus free shipping
thing at mytartcherry.com Walsh this is
their best offer available anywhere
that's my tart cherry.com walls for up
to 35 percent off tart cherry gummies my
tart cherry.com these statements and
products have not been evaluated by the
FDA these products are not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease or condition
all right so here's an announcement for
you that I'll deliver by way of this
daily wire report former congresswoman
and Democratic presidential candidate
Tulsi gabbard will be speaking at a
Friday rally to end child mutilation led
by daily wire host Matt Walsh that's me
at the Tennessee State Capitol gabbard
who introduced a Bill in Congress to uh
in December 2020 that would have banned
biological males from competing women's
sports joins a host of other high
profile speakers who are scheduled to
attend the rally in uh in Nashville so
that's the announcement is that uh Tulsa
gabbard's going to be speaking as as
well at the um at the rally so we've got
a we've got a wide range and I think
this is this is great we've got a wide
range of people
um uh represented uh speaking at this
rally Tulsa gabbard's going to be there
uh Senator Marshall Blackburn will be
speaking we're going to have um a couple
different state lawmakers here in
Tennessee who are heading up the uh the
fight to
to actually ban uh child mutilation in
the State uh Dr Colin Wright's going to
be there Chloe Cole who's a
de-transitioner and an activist is going
to be there Scott Nugent from uh from
what is a woman
uh also will be speaking at the rally
and many more as well so
this is going to be as I said wide range
of people lots of voices represented and
that's what the left wants right that's
what they say they want you want
representation is so important well
we're going to have that at this rally
um
a lot of different types of people
speaking different backgrounds but all
of us with the same goal to protect
children from being horrifically abused
and mutilated
once again that's four o'clock outside
the state capitol in Nashville
um obviously
the larger the crowd the better because
we're trying again this is not just
about pushing for
a law here in Tennessee
to make this kind of thing illegal
that's a big part of the the plan that's
what that is what we're advocating for
but it goes beyond that as well
you know this is about building a
national movement
to protect children and also to just
stand for basic truth and moral decency
so really hope to see you all there
moving on to this AOC is having more
trouble at her Town Hall events and
let's uh
we saw the footage last week she was at
a town hall event sparsely attended and
she was being shouted down by protesters
protesters from the left who were
accusing her of being a warmonger going
along with uh the United States you know
involvement in Ukraine and accusing her
of
being part of the problem ushering us
towards potentially nuclear conflict all
of that is true
and here once again she's at another
town hall event and uh the audience not
big fans it would seem let's check this
out
talking for 20 minutes
we know why we know why you're mad let's
talk about it
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
lights out
you know there is a it's a slightly
bigger crowd
so that's good at least for him
I'm not just standing outside the
building oh now she comes back in all
right
so you get the idea
crowd not heavy so it's slightly bigger
now at the Town Hall event last week it
was a room about that size and there
were maybe five people sitting in the
room and in this case she's got a good
solid crowd of probably 20 or 30 people
so give her some credit for that that's
nice but um it seems like a certain
portion of that crowd are only there
because they want to yell at her which
once again I I think that's it's
fantastic this is this is the treatment
that politicians deserve now in many
other contexts
um if you're going to watch a speech or
a talk or a panel discussion or
something like that yeah you should be
in the audience screaming and shouting
and disrupting you shouldn't be doing
that
um
even if it's left this up on the stage
but with politicians totally different
ball game
and when it's a politician like AOC this
is the treatment that she should be
getting people should be yelling at her
and uh
basically showing as much respect for
her as she shows for them
which is none at all
that's the way it's supposed to work
like in theory right these are public
servants so in theory they work for us
and the respect should come that way you
show respect for us and maybe we'll
return it to you but if you don't have
any respect for us we're not gonna have
respect for you
is this is a a that's what a healthy
democracy looks like that what you just
saw there
that's what a healthy democracy looks
like and sounds like
ineffectual
worthless useless politicians being
yelled at by their constituents it's a
beautiful thing it's music's my ears I
love it
and she has nothing to offer them
she has nothing to say to them
this is we talked about in the opening
as as a as a far left Democrat
she's not worried about what's going on
in their lives she's not worried about
you know helping them flourish which is
what she should be doing she should be
advocating policies that are all
directed towards uh human flourishing
but she has the the opposite intentions
and they're letting her know about it
since we're on the subject of Democrats
embarrassing themselves I want to just
throw this in as well briefly here's a
South Carolina Democratic Congressional
candidate named Annie Andrews uh in a
debate I think this was this week
and she was asked who will pay for the
health care plan that she has outlined
and let's watch that Exchange
and who pays for their plan Dr Andrews
30 seconds I'm sorry who pays for your
plan
how would that plan be paid for so we
just we need to focus on delivering high
quality health care that focuses on
prevention and that becomes more
affordable we need to get big Pharma and
big Insurance out of this so that we can
focus on our patients and delivering
high quality preventable Hair Care
Health Care which is evidence-based and
cost effective
so not answering the question who pays
for the plan I'm sorry what was that who
pays for the plan sorry I can't hear you
I I have a water clog in my ears I was I
took a bath earlier
well the answer is of course the
taxpayers pay for which doesn't want to
say that out loud
um
for some reason they're they're always
quite hesitant to actually say out loud
that well here here are all of our plans
and by the way all of this is coming
directly out of your pocket of course
the reason they don't want to say that
is because they present all of these
ideas especially when it comes to
something like healthcare they present
it as oh we're giving this to you for
free we're going to provide you with
free health care free this free that
well they then have to admit that you
are paying for the free thing then
you'll quickly understand that it's not
free at all
right couple of stories here having to
do with the situation in uh our school
system first Tim Ryan in Ohio hopefully
about to lose to uh JD Vance in a couple
of weeks here has this to say about our
schools
we have to have honest conversations
about and we've got people who want to
turn our schools when we should be
focused on shop class and
trauma-informed care and robust
investments into joint vocational
schools
they want to turn our schools into the
next Battleground in the culture wars
we can't let them
we can't let them
it's up to us
yeah oh we're we are turning the schools
into a Battleground in the culture War
we're doing that so on the left they're
putting pornographic material in the
schools and they're uh you know they
won't have conversations about gender
identity and transgenderism with
kindergarteners
and they want that so badly that if say
in Florida you pass a law that simply
says you can't talk about transgenderism
with kids between K through third grade
if you do that they're gonna the left
loses their mind about it and hasn't
stopped losing their mind over so that's
what they're doing but we're the ones
turning it into a Battleground the
culture War
and and am I am I saying that the left
on their own has made education a
Battleground in the culture War no I
wouldn't even say that
I mean it's education that we're talking
about inevitably it's going to be a
Battleground in the culture War
because the education system determines
so much
of our culture
the education system to a large extent
shapes our culture decides
what the culture is
and so if there's a culture War it's
going to end up in the school system
inevitably
speaking of the school system axios has
this report the average ACT test score
for students in the class of 2022
dropped to its lowest level of more than
three decades according to information
out on Wednesday the decline in store
scores is the latest indicator of the
pandemic's detrimental effects on the
nation's students and underscores the
extent to which graduating high school
students are ill-prepared for college
act CEO Janet Godwin says the magnitude
of the declines this year is
particularly alarming as we
see rapidly growing numbers of seniors
leaving high school without meeting the
college readiness Benchmark in any of
the subjects we measure
the national average composite score for
graduating seniors in 2022 was 19.8 out
of 36 which is the lowest score since
1991 and down from 20.3 for graduating
seniors in 2021. in addition 42 percent
of students failed to meet any of the
act's subject benchmarks and English
reading science and math which are the
minimum test scores required for
students to have a reasonable chance of
success in typical first-year college
courses
um act then there's this part which is
important
ACT test scores have been on the decline
for at least five years Godwin said
adding that it is a worrisome Trend that
began long before the disruption of the
kova 19 pandemic and has persisted okay
that's an important qualifier here
because when you hear this this claim
that uh the pandemic has caused test
scores to go down and kids are less
ready for college or whatever
uh first of all the pandemic
didn't do any of that
the pandemic itself
had no effect on test scores
that's not how pandemics work
the pandemics aren't going to make test
scores take a nosedive
pandemics don't have anything to do with
test scores this is if it's related to
the pandemic at all it's about how we
responded to the pandemic and when I say
we I mean we I mean the government
is what the government did and what the
school system did it's part of the
government
in response to the pandemic
shutting down schools for a year and in
some cases almost two years
you didn't have to do that they decided
to do that
and obviously when you shut down the
schools for extended periods of time
um you are going to see kids performing
you're going to see academic performance
decline that's it's it's not a surprise
and it is uh
incredibly frustrating to read stories
like this in the media
especially because there's always this
uh this tone of surprise to it
shock and surprise and alarm and they're
raising the alarm now and say oh look
what happened because of the the
pandemic response
yeah we told all of you that in the
beginning
we told you that from day one that this
would happen
and we were shouted down for years
and now you come along when it's too
late
and say oh okay you were right about
that only you're not even saying you
were right you're not acknowledging that
we were right
but
also it's important to note as it does
at the end there that we've been
trending in the wrong direction for
years so the pandemic response not the
pandemic the pandemic response
aggravated or exacerbated a problem that
already existed
um so this is you can't even put it all
on the pandemic response
the education system is failing and has
been failing for years and has for years
been trending in exactly the wrong
direction
and I say all that even though I don't I
don't like standardized tests I'm
skeptical about tests in general as a
means of gauging a student's grasp on
the subject
um
I certainly don't agree with teaching to
the test as as all of the schools do
that's the way the system is set up
that the goal of of any class it's not
really to help kids have a grasp on the
subject matter it's not to make them
more knowledgeable and intelligent
certainly it's just to make sure that
they can score well on the test
and then head off to the four-year
institution that's what the entire
system is set up for
a while on the test go go spend uh six
figures on a four-year Institution
that's it
I I don't agree with any of that
I don't think that should be the goal of
the education system and again I'm I am
extremely skeptical of standardized
tests and the idea that you can
sufficiently gauge a student's grasp on
understanding the subject through a test
I think what you're actually gauging is
the ability of a student to memorize
certain bits of information and
regurgitate them onto
you know a uh onto a sheet of paper
that's what you're gauging
memorization and regurgitation
which which by the way is uh it's a
helpful skill to have
and it could can come in handy even
later in life but it's it doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with
actually understanding the subject
which is why you can have kids who make
it through school and get really and and
get uh admirable grades and they perform
well on the tests and then they become
adults and you go and you try to have a
conversation with them about any subject
at all and it becomes clear that they
don't know anything
they did well in the test but they don't
actually know anything
but that's how I feel about it the point
is that the school by their own
standards
are failing the schools by their own
standards are failing
by their own strategies they're failing
this is how they've set it up is that
everything is judged based on the tests
and they've set up the entire system
that way the entire system exists for
the tests
and they can't even and the kids are
still failing on the tests
foreign so the schools are not not even
just a failure by my standards or by the
you know by the standards of people who
are critical fundamentally critical of
the government education system but
they're even a failure by the school's
own standards
all right so you've seen this Dylan
Mulvaney fellow quite a lot um he's been
selected by the powers that be
to be a thing and not just be a thing
but to be the spokesman for Womanhood
and we've seen a few videos from him I
just wanna I want you to I want to show
you this because this is a one of his
latest Tick Tock videos
sponsored by instacart
okay this dude has all kinds of
corporate sponsorships now
and this is one of his latest just just
watch this
you know what I think we need a good
old-fashioned sleepover
so much of what I'm doing online is
reliving the moments of girlhood that I
missed out on including sleepovers where
I could be silly with my friends all
night long without a care in the world
so I put together a Dylan sleepover
Essentials list on instacart that y'all
can shop to get my dream sleepover
experience
huh speaking of my order is here
I have the delivery first things first
skin care and I'm warning you beforehand
I eat mostly junk food but we're having
a sleepover so it's allowed oh the
pizza's ready
oh they're hot it's hot I still have
room in my dessert stomach so we're
having ice cream
I think we start with prank calls and
then put a finger down then we'll go
around and manifest all of our dreams
and goals for the rest of the year then
a rom-com and then we can paint our
nails and we're gonna stay up all night
long visit the link in my bio to shop
Dylan's sleepover Essentials via
instacart now love ya
all right
I have to remind you again
not that you need to remind her it's
quite obvious
that is a grown man
as a grown adult man
not just identifying as a woman which is
not
but as a as a child as a girl
and what he says there in the video
sponsored by instacart
that he's reliving the girlhood that he
missed out on
he is playing the part of a of a of an
adolescent girl
to call that creepy and concerning and
to say that it raises red flags would be
uh an understatement
and yet that's sponsored by instacart
so it's just it's sort of amazing the
extent to which
all of these corporate brands
have selected this guy I mean so he's
he's just he's a guy
a creep and then one day he decides as a
as a tick tock stunt that he's going to
transition not into a woman but into an
adolescent girl
and almost immediately
some of the biggest brands of
corporations in the country are lining
up to give this guy money and make him
into a mascot for them
just skipping over all a bunch of actual
women if they wanted a a real woman to
represent if instacart wanted an actual
woman on Tick Tock to promote their
products uh I'm sure they could find
plenty
but they go right to the the guy
playing the part of
a teenage girl
all right
another big air travel controversy Yahoo
reports this we've had a lot of heavy
stuff so something slightly less serious
though still pretty serious
um Yahoo says where do you stand or sit
as the case may be on a controversial
air travel issue for years
people have weighed in on whether they
or other passengers should fully recline
their seats during a flight especially
amid a long flight because the act of
reclining that seat means the person
seated behind the airplane chair will
have far less space than otherwise
people are vehement on both sides of the
issue
now comes further discussion and
controversy a user on Reddit named
cherry
ham123
so it's a Reddit user named Cherry Hamm
who posted something on Reddit and and
it's it makes it into the news
I guess I can't judge all these news
outlets for constantly mining Reddit for
Content because I mean I do that all the
time also but then again I'm not this is
not a news program
anyway Cherry ham recently shared that
uh she was on a flight to the U.S from
Australia 14 hours she had it and
sometime into the flight I reclined my
seat to sleep but then the person posted
the girl behind me poked me and told me
to not recline my seat because she was
uncomfortable what is the etiquette here
Fox News digital reached out to the user
for comment
re-winter in Australian replied and
shared further details of her trip with
Fox News digital via email
if the news outlets reaching out for
comment about someone because they had
an issue reclining their seat on a plane
she says I was flying to America to see
my partner it was a flight to LAX after
the one behind me poked my seat
repeatedly I turned to look at her and
she then told me that she was trying to
watch a movie and I shouldn't recline my
seat
winter told Fox News digital further
about the incident it's a 14-hour flight
so you really want to be able to sleep
through some of it when it was obvious
that this woman thought she was in the
right and was going to continue to annoy
me I called a flight attendant explain
the situation and asked if I could move
seats winter said the attendant was
happy to oblige since there were a
couple of seats vacant
um and then anyway so the other Reddit
users chimed in and gave their own
opinions about it should you recline the
seat should you not uh this to me and
I'm just going to make the definitive
Declaration on this one because they say
that it's a controversy it's really not
a controversy at all it's really quite
simple
if you want to be treated
vaguely like a human being on a plane
you need to sit in first class okay you
have to pay the extra
depending on how long flight is maybe
the extra thousand dollars
for first class because that is it's not
even that you get necessarily luxury In
First Class it's just you'll have
human-like conditions and you can do
things like recline your seat
that's what first class is for if you're
sitting in coach
because you don't want to pay the extra
money then you're you're basically not
human for the for the duration of the
flight I don't like it I'm not saying it
should be that way but that's that's how
it is you're packed in there you're
treated like livestock and uh that's
just it you have you have to that's part
of the bargain now
which means that yeah you might think
yeah I paid for the seat I should be
able to recline it no you can't you
cannot recline the seat
that's the verdict here
reclining seats that's you got to pay a
thousand dollars and sit in first class
but you don't recline your seat and
coach
it's one of the most selfish things you
can do because you are yeah you're
restful but you you are directly the
person behind you has about four inches
of leg room you're going to recline that
seat so you can catch you can catch some
z's and get an app or whatever and
you're taking all of that space away
how can you even sleep knowing that
you're doing that I don't know how you
sleep on a plane in general but how do
you sleep knowing that you're sleeping
in the lap of a stranger behind you
and not only that but they they the
entire time well you're resting you know
that they're sitting there stewing in
anger and just glaring at you because
they can't do anything else they can't
watch a movie on uh they can't watch the
screen that's on the back because you've
reclined it so they can't watch a movie
they can't read a book they can't do
work because you've reclined your seat
they can't use the tray table they can't
eat
the plane shouldn't be set up this way
but they are
I don't even know how you sleep what
kind of sociopath do you need to be
to be able to sleep in those conditions
so that's it that's the that's the
verdict now we can all move on
now let's get to our comment section
[Music]
[Music]
James French says you're such an
influence to me Matt I I've quit emojis
cold turkey and my mind feels clear for
it
just as I have never felt more aligned
with Matt Walsh than I was during his
Emoji rant
WP Max says uh Matt my fellow I'm almost
with you on the Emoji front I hate
emojis in almost every single instance
the only time I use them is with my wife
and it's never in place of communication
I only use them to accentuate a
statement that I make prior to its use
but they should never be used in place
of linguistic communication and never in
a business uh interaction it's just
unprofessional
using Emojis with your wife you're going
to emasculate yourself that way
by using emojis
and you say you use the emoji
extend you accentuate a statement
prior to its use
so you put the you put the Emoji before
the statement you're about to make
I don't even understand that
although I was there there were a lot of
comments that were in support of my
anti-emoji position which uh I was
relieved to see that I was also
surprised because what I see when I look
out in the world is like everyone is
using emojis
and so I'm wondering of all the people
that are now saying they agree with me
in principle you shouldn't use them are
you using them anyway
because there should be if we're all
anti-emoji then this should be a pretty
easy problem to solve Jesus saves says
you're so right about people who attempt
to make a middle ground by agreeing to
the most common of the Absurd new takes
by the way the control room is putting
emojis up on the screen as I speak
because this is
what I have uh
this is going to haunt me for the rest
of my life you're so right about people
who attempt to take a middle ground by
agreeing to the most common of the
Absurd new takes I saw the same thing
when people started to say that
homosexuality is fine but I can't agree
with transgender now it's I'll call
people the wrong pronoun as long as the
pronoun exists eventually they will
allow for more and more if we don't
stand on the truth then we'll keep uh
falling for more and more evil or as I
said yesterday if you are willing when
it comes to the pronoun thing
if you're willing to abandon what you
know is true
um in order to go along with the crowd
or because you want to be polite or
whatever else it is you're willing to do
that then
you you've opened the door and there are
there are no limits anymore
uh
okay another comment says weeb is short
for weebu
which used to be a derogatory term
coined on the Chans to refer to Western
anime fans that had an overly idealized
impression of Japan that bordered on
Obsession these days it could be a
derogatory term referring to someone
whose engagement with the fandoms of
Japanese media is bleeding over into
their other social interactions
it can also be a term of endearment or
self-description that refers simply to
enjoying Japanese media okay I did ask
what weeb means and uh I got the
explanation and I stopped caring halfway
through reading it but now I know at
least
McKinley says I will never get over the
irony of the people who claim to always
support science and follow what the
science says being the ones who support
all of this nonsense it's one of their
many contradictions obviously but it's
also worth you know noting that their
conception of science their idea of what
science is
is totally confused I could do a
follow-up to what is a woman called what
is science and it would also be a
stumper for the left it's it's it's
actually a good question to ask them
when they start talking about the
science says this and that
you ask them what is science what do you
mean that the science says this what do
you think it means
because what what they actually think
science means is uh they think that
science is an institution that's what
they think they think that it's science
is like an organization
and it has Representatives it has
Gatekeepers it has people who hold the
magical secrets of the universe and if
those people and those institutions
declare something
then the science declares it by
extension
fauci said this about himself almost
verbatim multiple times he is the
science he represents the science he
said and that is how the the left sees
it
but
that's not science okay you know what
science is you know how you define it
very simple
science is a process of understanding
the physical world
and every part of that definition is
important because it is focused on the
physical world
science can only tell you about the
physical world now if you're a
materialist you would say that all there
is is the physical world there's nothing
outside of it I would say that there's
more to reality than the physical world
but either way all science can do is
deal with the physical world
and when it comes to the physical world
um it is a process of understanding it's
not a declaration it's not a statement
it's not a verdict
um it is a process of understanding
So when you say the science says XYZ
it actually doesn't make any sense
because science doesn't say anything
people say things so people can use
science that is they can they can engage
in a process of understanding the
physical world and they can arrive at
conclusions and they can tell you what
those conclusions are that's not the
science speaking that's the person
and maybe they're right about the
conclusions or maybe they're wrong
so it's kind of like it's like um
looking through a telescope and then
saying the telescope says that the Moon
is right there
well the telescope doesn't say anything
the telescope is just a tool it's uh
it's a tool that you use to see what is
there
and you're probably right that the Moon
is there
but it's you saying that it's not the
telescope the telescope is just the tool
that that magnified uh the physical
realities that you so you could see them
better and same thing with with science
all right
thorium says I used to be SBG but now
I'm now a proud Cooper Trooper we are
the superior gang
well you were never SBG okay that's one
of the one of the fundamental rules here
what's what's rule number one of SBG we
don't explain it to anyone
rule number two is that you never leave
and if you do leave then you were never
in it to begin with
you can't you can't you can't
you can't do that
and can I take something else too
I assume it's the Brett Cooper's her
fans are Cooper Trooper you can't no you
can't make your own gang it has to
develop see the beauty of SBG is that it
it was it was meant to be it was written
in the stars I didn't I didn't invent it
it just happened it almost grew out of
the the ground almost it was like it's
organic
the world was crying out for it it just
came into being
you can't decide one day oh I'm gonna
have my own call it's not how it works
so here's what I'll say I will accept
Cooper Trooper if you wanna I'll accept
that as a as a
a subdivision of the sweet baby gang I'm
okay with that okay you can have your
own little clubs or whatever within the
sweet baby gang
organization
but there is only one gang there's only
one cult here at the daily wire
and be very clear about that are you
still giving your money to woke razor
companies that hate your values see
masculinity as toxic and think you
should teach your daughter how to shave
her beard well there is a although if
she has a beard you probably should
shave it so
but she probably doesn't is the point
anyway
There's A Better Way Jeremy's razors are
100 real and 100 woke free the premium
Matt tungsten handle has more heft than
the left the razor head pivots without
caving and has six blades that are
sharper than truth those other razor
companies they keep virtue signaling to
the totalitarian left and using your
money to do it but you don't have to let
them when you buy Jeremy's razors you
aren't just making Jeremy richer you're
making the woke left poorer 95 000
people have already made the switch
visit jeremy'srazors.com to get your
founder series shave kit today that's
jeremy'srazors.com Jeremy's razors shut
up and shave now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
Alexandra Hunt is a self-described
public health activist and Community
organizer whose failed Congressional bid
made the news due to the fact that she
was using only fans to raise money for
her campaign now In fairness to her lots
of politicians are prostitutes so she
was just being more honest about it you
might say before running for congress
hunt was for a brief period a stripper
and again you could argue that that was
relevant career experience for an
aspiring DC politician but now that her
political dreams have been put on hold
hunt has been able to get back to her
Public Health activism and that's what
she was apparently trying to do
presumably with a recent viral tweet
thread in which she tries to raise the
alarm that not enough people are having
sex she tweeted this quote young men
aren't having sex exclamation point
nearly a third of men under 30 have not
had sex and a higher percent do not have
as much sex as they'd like not exactly
surprising but this kind of statistic is
a sign of much deeper problems now she
then provides a chart from The
Washington Post which shows that 28 of
men under 30
haven't had sex in the past year not
that there are virgins necessarily as
hunt seems to claim yet even still it is
indicative of a real problem
the question is whether she will
interpret the problem correctly and
offer helpful Solutions
and if we know anything about the left
we know that there really isn't a
question here at all the answer on both
counts is obviously no
so she continues our society
criminalizes sex and sweeps it under the
rug the consequences are straightforward
there's more violence since platforms
like Craigslist were banned from
advertising sex serious violent crimes
against all women not just sex workers
has increased by nearly a fifth
a man who uh and men who do not have sex
suffer they're less likely to be a part
of the labor force they're more likely
to experience depression nihilism other
mental health issues the metoo movement
accomplished so much and we have to take
the next step normalizing having healthy
positive consensual sex
decriminalizing sex work funding sets
education and creating Outreach programs
that help young people develop healthy
sexual habits we should be moving toward
a right to sex people should be able to
have sex when they feel they want to and
we need to develop services that meet
people's needs without attaching the
baggage of shame or criminalization so
let's talk about sex we need to bring
these discussions to the spotlight
normalizing healthy positive sex will
have too many Downstream benefits to
list we need to move past our history of
Shame it's time to bring sex into the
light
okay
well this is just a mess the train has
gone careening catastrophically off the
rails and that's all the more
frustrating because in this case for
once the train was actually initially on
the rails at least partially at first
she identified a real problem part of a
real problem but that's where in her
insights ended
they ended because to summarize
she located a problem caused by the
sexual Revolution
and then sought to fix it
with Solutions given to her by the
sexual Revolution
she's trying to put out the Flames by
smothering it with dry kindling in other
words so let's go through this more
thoroughly because it is an important
issue
um but but what is the issue exactly yes
large numbers of younger men and women
aren't having sex more to the point
however they're not in romantic
relationships they're they're not
married
the numbers show that the average age of
marriage is getting pushed back
precipitously more and more each year
and as this is happening more and more
men and again women too are dropping out
of the dating pool entirely all but
giving up waving the White Flag so the
lack lack of sex is one significant
feature of the actual underlying concern
which is that people are increasingly
giving up on meaningful romantic
relationships with other flesh and blood
human beings
hunt doesn't seem worried about the
human relationship part she thinks that
as long as we can you know have sex with
each other again uh everything will be
fine if everyone could just go out there
and and have sex everything's fine
doesn't matter who they're having sex
with or in what context all that matters
is the sex she thinks
we could even have government issued
prostitutes or else we could give a
sex-starved Americans an EBT style
credit card that they can go and use at
the local tax-funded whorehouse
like any other Progressive
hunt has decided that everything comes
down to sex and the solution as always
is just more and more sex she believes
that somehow our society is not open
enough about the subject we need to talk
about it more we need to stop sweeping
it under the rug as she phrases it but
this can't possibly be the problem
because there has never been a more sex
saturated culture than ours
everybody with an internet connection or
a smartphone including children can
access at lightning speed literally
billions of hours of pornography
whenever they want and even if they
don't want to access it pornography will
be put in front of their faces
everywhere sex is everywhere it's talked
about everywhere
they put porn in grade school libraries
gay bars host drag queen strip shows for
children as a culture we need more
exposure to sex in the same way that a
guy on his third played the Chinese
buffet needs another serving of food
the problem is not in the lack of sexual
exposure
but rather mourn its over abundance and
also in the type of sexual exposure
we're talking about
hunt says that
um we need all this sexual stuff and and
uh indeed a lot more of it because we
all have a right to sex
now that's clearly ridiculous so I'm not
going to spend a lot of time chopping
down that particular tree nobody has a
right to sex because if you have a right
to something but if you have a right to
something
that a person who withholds that thing
from you
has infringed on your rights so the
implication then would obviously be that
if a person uh who who doesn't have sex
with you has committed a moral crime
against you that's the implication
like they don't have a right to not have
sex with you if Hunt's idea is correct
and this becomes a justification for
rape and all manner of other atrocities
that may not be what she directly
intends but that is the consequence of
turning sex into a human right
which which it is not
so her Insight on this subject is
obviously quite limited to put it
generously
uh what then are the actual causes of
the problem well here are a few we're
thinking about
first as mentioned uh pornography
okay there's been plenty of research
done on this actual credible research
which consistently shows that people who
regularly view pornography become less
interested in romantic relationships
this applies also to people actually in
romantic relationships which is part of
the reason why pornography used to just
tied to higher rates of divorce
porn along with being morally degenerate
and spiritually corrosive is a source of
kind of empty calories it satiates the
human desire for companionship and
romance
except that it does so in the most
superficial sort of way
a man who is hungry for food might fill
up by you know eating chips and drinking
soda but he's not actually being
nourished and in a similar way a man who
is desperate for the company of a woman
might get his fill with pornography but
he's not actually satisfying that deep
longing of his heart
he's numbing himself so that he doesn't
feel it as much at least in the moment
second hunt gives credit to the metoo
movement but of course the metoo
movement is a major source of the
problem
a man who would otherwise be inclined to
go out and pursue a woman is now
terrified that he'll trip over any of
the countless land mines that are buried
all over the dating scene
he's worried that even if he tries to
approach a woman pay her a compliment
flirt with her ask her out Etc he'll
find himself accused of sexual
harassment or worse
and third
what lies at the root of all of this
is demoralization
a lack of purpose a lack of meaning
despair
hunt mentions nihilism but she thinks
that nihilism is caused by
or a side effect of the lack of sexual
relationships but it goes the other way
around
a man doesn't give up on female
companionship and then become a nihilist
he becomes a nihilist and then gives up
on female companionship
she is pointing to an issue that is much
farther Downstream
the problem is not simply that men
aren't having sex but that they aren't
getting married to begin with
and the problem is not simply that they
aren't getting married but that they
struggle to see the purpose or meaning
in marriage
or in anything else
and the problem is not simply that men
don't have purpose in their lives but
that we live in a culture that breeds
purpose purposelessness and despair
the culture has signposts all along the
road pointing in a certain direction and
if you follow those signs and you walk
down that way it will lead you directly
off a cliff
where you'll wind up in a moral and
spiritual free fall all the way down
into a cold dark abyss
Alexandra hunt as a leftist is one of
the people who's you know putting those
signs up
directing people into the pit
and as they fall into it she stands
around the edge shouting hey what's the
matter why are you so upset
and that is why she is today
finally canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block portion hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]